hey 42 here if you think of life on
Earth as a vast RPG where all the
different animals represent the various
playable classes we humans would be the
dictionary definition of a min max build
our intellect will be the Envy of every
other class in the game but our other
attributes would all be close to zero
we're weak we're slow we're fragile
we're awkward swimmers insecure climbers
and pathetic diggers we can't fight we
can't fly we can't hide and we don't
have any fancy adaptations like poison
sacks or camouflage skin
in short apart from the fact we've
managed to grow melon-sized brains
humans are totally that's why for
most of our history we weren't the
Undisputed apex predators that we are
today as we ferociously hunt Wendy's in
the Wilds of the American Strode instead
we were on the menu
foreign
were actively hunted by big cats even
bigger Bears wolves crocodiles hyenas
snakes and even Giant Eagle Soros as
human McMuffins these days most of the
wild animals even the big scary ones
have all had a big meeting and decided
it's best if we leave humans alone but
every so often an animal will lose its
innate fear of mankind and starts to
actively prey on humans and the results
can be terrifying how terrifying let me
pause it this way Harold Shipman also
known as duck for death is considered to
be the most prolific serial killer in
modern history during a criminal career
spanning over 22 years he's thought to
have killed a staggering 250 people
that's an almost unimaginable mountain
of murder and yet it pales in comparison
to the Bunker's body count of the most
prolific animal serial killer of all
time as for what kind of animal this
misanthropic mass murderer was and how
many victims it took now would be a good
time to place your bets in the comments
and trust me it's probably more than
your thinking are you tired of spending
precious time preparing meals when
you've got a busy schedule well huel is
fast food that's good for you heels hot
and savory range includes hot tasty
plant-based instant meals that give your
body all the good stuff it needs to
thrive it's 100 nutritionally complete
and contains 26 essential vitamins and
minerals and 24 grams of protein protein
is just one of the most important things
you can give your body to keep it
functioning optimally made with natural
ingredients fuels Hudson Savory range
makes for a perfect lunch or dinner
recently I've been really digging this
tomato and herb flavor with its fresh
tasting homegrown garden-like flavors
it's been a perfect lunch option during
these summer months fuel Hudson slavery
couldn't be any easier to make you
simply Add boiling water and then leave
it for five minutes that folks is
literally it and there you have it a hot
nutritious tasty meal did I mention it's
also really affordable so click the link
in the description to try huel today if
you use my special link you'll be
supporting the channel and with your
first order you'll also receive a free
Shaker a heel t-shirt and a guide to
help you get started and for the next 72
hours only if you use the code 4010 at
checkout you'll receive 10 pounds off a
one-time mortar of 40 pounds or Rover so
definitely don't miss out on that one
and a big thanks to hewell for
sponsoring this video
seen Disney's The Jungle Book you're
probably familiar with Baloo the happy
go lucky bear who Grooms sorry I meant
teaches Mowgli the Lords of the Jungle
in the original novel by Rudyard Kipling
Baloo is described as a sloth bear which
is ironic really because it turns out
sloth birds are responsible for more
attacks on humans than any other bear
species on the planet
so if the Jungle Book was a documentary
blue would have ripped little mowgli's
face into a thousand pieces and eaten
his organs shame they didn't do that bit
in the live-action remake most sloth
bear attacks are defensive in nature but
on rare occasions an individual will
deliberately seek out and attack humans
in 1957 in the southern Indian states of
Mysore one particular sloth bear went
off Freddy Krueger on the locals by
viciously mauling more than 30 people
killing 12 and partially consuming at
least three though some animal rights
activists argue the Beast was simply
looking for the bare necessities it
needed to survive I'm so sorry my sorry
sloth bear kill count 12. these days
large Predators have been all but
exterminated for much of Western Europe
but things were very different back in
the 18th century back then when Forrest
still covered much of the continent
wolves Lynx Wolverine jackals and Bear
as was still relatively common and it
was in 18th century France that our next
Manita got his first taste of human
flesh it all started in 1764 in the
former French province of javudon when a
14 year old girl was killed whilst
shepherding her sheep over the following
monster body count surged and the
pattern emerged almost all the victims
were women or children and most were
killed by having their throats torn out
by early 1765 the Beast had racked up a
kill count that would make Rambo look
like Barbie with a potato gun becoming
one of France's first ever national news
stories word of The Killing Spree even
reached King Louis XV himself and he
decreed that the creature should be
eliminated at any cost
it was just one small problem nobody
seemed to know what the hell it actually
was those who'd seen the Beast mostly
agreed it looked broadly like a wolf but
with only a few notable differences
starters as it were said to be
significantly bigger the size of a small
cow
but people claimed it had a long slender
tail a stubby snout and unusual fur
colorings and patterns whatever this
fugly hippie wolf cow was it needed a
good killing and word was put out that
whoever brought the monster down would
be paid a year's salary as a reward the
response was predictably enthusiastic
some 30 000 people joined the hunt
several local walls were soon
slaughtered by the Pitchfork wielding
mob and plenty of people tried to claim
the reward but the deaths continued
unabated for the following 18 months in
the end it was a local farmer who ended
the Madness by killing the whack job
hippie wolf cow Beast with a silver
bullet some historians believe that's
the reason we associate silver bullets
with werewolves to this day but what
exactly was the Beast of jevudon
unfortunately we still don't know for
sure by the time a post-mortem could be
carried out the remains had largely
rotted away the most popular theory is
that the animal was simply a large wolf
but not everyone agrees after all your
average 18th century French peasant
would have been pretty familiar with
what a wolf looked like it was one of
only three questions a peasant would
have gotten right in a pub quiz along
with what do you put in a passage and in
two short sentences describe the
reciprocal influence of feudal
structures on the Labyrinth and
evolution of social political Dynamics
and economic paradigms within your local
fifth some people believe the Beast was
a lion or perhaps a hyena that had
escaped from some rich tits Menagerie
others predictably went full werewolf
it's even been suggested the whole thing
was a cover story for the 18th Century's
most prolific serial killer some crazed
psychopath who went around murdering
women and children dressed in wolfskin
that reminds me I really need to burn
that thing
whatever the truth the killings
themselves really did happen 210 attacks
were documented in total with 113 people
killed and 49 injured 98 of the victims
were at least partially devoured by the
creature
potentially a wolf kill count 130.
of all the animals that have snacked on
Homo sapiens over the Millennia lions
are probably the best known man-eaters
and amongst man-eating Lions none are
more famous than those of the Savo
region in Kenya back in the late 19th
century when the British mistook all the
other countries for Pokemon cards and
tried to catch them all they began the
construction of a railway line that
would link Uganda with the colony of
Kenya we'd love to go to railway back
then the Uganda Railway would eventually
span some 700 miles but size isn't what
the Project's known for today no the
Uganda Railway is famous for the pair of
man-eating Lions who stalked the men
that built it
one of the trickiest parts of the build
was a bridge over the Savo River several
thousand unskilled laborers were brought
in from British India to get the job
done and as was tradition in those days
they were paid a suitably insulting wage
and put up in simple camps nearby to
maximize their time spent working all
textbook Colonial stuff unfortunately
the camps just so happened to be smack
in the middle of the territory of two
unusually large mainless male lions
nobody knows for sure why the beasts
developed a taste for man flesh but
perhaps they simply figured that
compared to say an antelope humans were
about as difficult to catch as an
arthritic tortoise either way once they
went full human snack the Lions never
went back and they proved to be
frighteningly efficient human Hunters
creeping into the camps at night and
dragging men screaming from their tents
before devouring them undercover of
Darkness to begin with the attacks were
sporadic but as the Lions grew Bolder
they came almost every night with each
lion dragging away a man to itself the
workers responded by building fences
made from woven phone bushes and keeping
fires burning throughout the night but
it didn't work at first the men in
charge weren't overly concerned you
can't make an omelet without breaking a
few eggs and you can't build a railway
without a few people being eaten by
lions everybody knows that but then
something far scarier than man-eating
Lions befell the project the workers
went on strike
a few dozen men getting eaten by lions
was unfortunate but profits being lost
to Industrial action was downright
unacceptable the railway Tycoon sent a
couple of officials to find out just
what the hell was going on and they did
so in truly spectacular fashion because
within hours of their arrival one of
them had been killed and eaten by the
Lions and the other had lacerations all
down his back if you really can't make
this stuff up can you anyway as luck
would have it the man in charge of
overseeing the construction of the
Railway Lieutenant's Colonel John Henry
Patterson also happens to be an
experienced Hunter and with the help of
20 armed men both of the lions were
eventually shot according to official
estimates between them the Savo
man-eaters killed a staggering 135 men
in the space of just nine months almost
all of them were eaten the Lion's
reputation was so fearsome that their
deaths was announced by British prime
minister Lord Salisbury in the House of
Lords and their stuff skins can still be
seen in the field museum of natural
history in Chicago to this day more than
100 years later sovere lions kill count
135. in my recent video on the ramri
island Massacre I examined the weird
World War II battle in which hundreds of
Japanese soldiers were allegedly killed
by crocodiles there were countless hot
water Crocs in the ramri mangrove swamp
during the battle so it's impossible to
know how many men were eaten by Any
Given individual but there is one
crocodile whose epic kill count has
become a modern day legend in the small
African nation of Burundi his name is
Gustav and I don't know why he was given
the name of a friend similar but this
Nile crocodile is truly gigantic
estimated to be well over six meters
long and weighing in it over a ton
Gustavo is amongst the largest
crocodiles on the whole African
continent but it isn't just his size
that makes him stand out he also has
three distinctive bullet wounds on his
back trophies from Hunters who have
tried and failed to end his bloody reign
of terror it's fought that Gustav
retired from wine tasting and began
murdering in the 1970s plucking his
victims from the banks of the rozizi
river and the northern shakes of Lake
Tanganyika some people believe he's
guessing his revenge for those bullet
wounds whilst others think he's grown
too large and slow to catch fish which
typically make up the bulk of the Nile
crocodile's diet there are rumors online
that Gustav may actually have been
killed in unknown circumstances in 2019
but there's no proof so he could just be
doing a two-pack and hiding in a toilet
in Mexico
dead or not the locals still fear Him
Gustav that is not Tupac and for good
reason he's killed an estimated 200
people his near mythical status makes
that figure somewhat hard to trust but
whatever the truth Gustav is considered
a big enough problem that there have
been multiple attempts to kill or
capture him over the years in the early
2000s a team of scientists went full
Jurassic Park by attempting to coax him
into a cage through the Strategic use of
a live goat tied to a wooden Pole
the Trap was laid overnight but when the
team returned the following morning the
giant iron cage had been upended and the
Goat was gone nobody knows what happened
to Gustav but I'm going to go out on a
limb here and guess that things didn't
end too well for the goat Gustav kill
count 200.
200 kills by a single animal is
absolutely crazy but believe it or not
that's still a hell of a long way short
of the record in fact it isn't even
halfway there so any ideas which beast
wears the human consumption Crown if you
guessed Mongoose then congratulations
you are officially insane
and if you guessed killer rabbit with
big pointy teeth then you've obviously
been watching too much Monty Python if
on the other hand you guess tiger you
are 100
correct these days Tigers pose
relatively little threat to humans but
that isn't because they aren't deadly
we're just significantly deadlier we've
shot trapped and squeezed him into tiny
pockets of wilderness until the wild
tiger population is about four percent
of what it was 100 years ago
and about twice as many tigers are held
in captivity than live in the wild but
before we hunted them to the brink of
Extinction tigers with a single
deadliest species known to man
responsible for more human deaths than
any other wild animal excluding disease
carriers like mosquitoes and the music
of Jake Paul according to one study
almost 400 000 people have been killed
by tigers since the year 1800 and since
those are just the documented cases the
true number is far higher that's a
mind-blowing stat so it's fitting that
the deadliest animal to have ever lived
that we know about at least was a tiger
well not a tiger a tigress but I digress
known today as a champawat Manita this
magnificent Monster killed an almost
unbelievable 436 people at the turn of
the 20th century and it took one of
history's most legendary Hunters to
finally end her record-breaking Killing
Spree I fully grown Bengal tiger is a
force of nature weighing in at around
200 kilos and measuring 3 meters from
nose to tail they can run up to 65
kilometers an hour and when they
inevitably catch up with whatever it is
they're chasing they're 10 centimeter
canines can bite down with the force of
a thousand pounds per square inch about
six times that of a human it would be
like being eaten by a hydraulic press
except there wouldn't be a Finnish man
filming it for YouTube the
champawatomanita first got a taste for
human flesh in Western Nepal in 1903. at
first a tiger would hunt down lone
villagers usually women and children
when they venture too far into the
forest to collect wood or forage for
food but just like the Savo Lions over
time she grew Bolder eventually just
sauntering into settlements in broad
daylight and picking people off at will
according to contemporary records The
Tigress racked up an astonishing 200
tales in the pole evading scores of
hunters in the process the situation got
so serious that the Army was called him
and whilst they were unable to take down
the tiger they did succeed in forcing
her over the border into India where she
promptly picked up where she'd left off
murdering her new neighbors left right
and sends her things got so bad that
local started boarding up their houses
refusing to step outside for anything
that wasn't life-threatening and more
than one Village was abandoned entirely
India was under British rule at the time
and as the Tiger's reputation grew the
Big Wigs decided to bring in the big
guns Jim Corbett is probably the most
famous Dangerous Game Hunter who ever
lived he specialized in hunting
man-eaters and by the time he hung up
his rifle in the late 1940s he killed
more than 20 of them with an estimated
total of 1 200 kills between them unlike
most hunters of the day Corbett mostly
hunted alone and on Fox considering any
other approach to be unsporting if he
was going to try and kill a man-eater it
was only fair that it should have a
chance to get him first and the
champawat Maneater very nearly did
Corbett tracked her down by following a
trail of blood after she took her 436
victim in 1907. but as he prepared to
take the killing shot The Tigress
charged Corbett fired off several shots
in quick succession with the tiger
eventually succumbing to her wounds just
six meters from where he stood the
champawat Manita is sometimes known as
the demon of champoa the name implies
that this was a creature hell-bent on
the destruction of mankind
and at first her kill count would seem
to back up that Viewpoint But the irony
is the champawat Manita was a man-made
problem in the first place when Corbett
examined her blood-soaked body he found
something interesting an old gunshot
wound a bullet had passed through to
tigress's skull breaking several teeth
along the way
it was a serious injury one that would
have prevented her from successfully
hunting bigger stronger prey in other
words the champawat Manita wasn't some
vengeful demon with a hatred for mankind
she was simply trying to survive forced
to adapt to a serious injury inflicted
by the very species she ended up
slaughtering I think there might be a
lesson in there somewhere champawat
Manita kill count 436.
thanks for watching